(bright upbeat music)
- There's this channel called Jubilee,
and they make videos where
it's a group of people.
One person doesn't belong,
and then everybody has to,
like, try to figure out,
who doesn't belong?
Hello friends it's me.
It's literally frozen.
Today we're gonna be Karen hunting.
- [Ragini] We brought together
six SSSniperWolf fans.
- I am a SSSniperWolf fan.
- I'm an SSSniperWolf fan.
- I'm a SSSniperWolf fan.
- I am a SSSniperWolf fan.
- [Ragini] And one secret SSSniperWolf.
- I am SSSniperWolf.
- SSSniperWolf?
- Who?
- Cares?
- Nice.
- [Ragini] If the group
discovers who SSSniperWolf is,
they win a cash prize.
If SSSniperWolf survives,
she wins the entire prize.
With cameras and mics off,
can they find the real SSSniperWolf?
This is "Odd One Out."
(gentle music)
- Hello friends it's me.
Today I am nervous.
I'm gonna play this like I
play a game of "Among Us."
I'm gonna try to make some friends.
If y'all wanna throw
somebody under the bus,
I'll help you.
- My strategy for this
game is to figure out
who has the most
off-the-wall quirky answers.
And I feel like it's really
hard for Lia to be normal.
(chuckling)
- I'm gonna look for
keywords that she says,
that I know she says in all of her videos.
- It looks like it's gonna be hard
to find out who the mole is.
I got butterflies in my titties,
so I'm nervous.
- I'm feeling very nervous for this.
- It's so weird to be in a
call with someone like her.
- I think we're gonna find her, for sure.
- I made a notepad and I
wrote down my fake persona.
My name's Miley.
I'm 20 years old.
I'm from Portland, Oregon.
I go to the university of Portland.
I watched PewDiePie's episode of this
and Cody Ko made an episode too,
and they both got voted
out the first round.
I wanna at least get past the first round.
- Hey.
(indistinct)
- Hi.
- (chuckling) Good afternoon, everyone.
That one definitely isn't me.
- Hmm, I don't think it's Erika.
She's being a little friendly.
- I'm peachy.
- I'm peachy?
I don't know Emily.
- That's not something
SSSniperWolf would say.
- I hope everyone's on
the same page as me,
like a slow typer, because I'd be like...
- I'm good.
I had to like rewrite that several times.
I'm like, wait, I can't say I'm nervous.
Why would I be nervous?
I'm not SSSniperWolf.
- Huh?
- Oh, shit, I shouldn't have said that.
- SSSniperWolf is from Arizona, so.
- I'm kind of suspicious of Ricky,
because SSSniperWolf is also from Arizona.
- What's your favorite game?
I'm gonna ask some questions.
(screen beeping)
I'm gonna say Fortnite.
Oh my God.
- I like ROBLOX. (chuckling)
- ROBLOX?
I think it's Brandon.
- I'ma ask who here likes "Bleach"
'cause SSSniperWolf's a big "Bleach" fan.
- Who here likes "Bleach?"
I can't say anything.
Ricky is being so suspicious right now.
You know, I walk into
every single conversation,
like, have y'all seen "Bleach?"
- I love "Bleach."
- She said, "I love 'Bleach.'"
- [I'm not, I'm just,
I'm gonna ignore the "Bleach" question.
I don't even--
- I know she's super into anime.
(screen beeps)
"Ricky is sus."
Okay, thank you.
Ricky is sus.
- I think Liz is sus though, I don't,
I don't think Ricky is sus.
I just feel like the way
she talks might be her,
and the beanie.
- I'm just agreeing with them.
I'm agreeing because he
says he's from Arizona.
He says he likes "Bleach."
- What's the defense?
- Ricky looking sus.
- The defense?
- I think Ricky is suspicious.
'Cause like who else brings anime
that quick into the chatroom?
- They're already saying I'm sus?
- I don't know, everyone seems so nice.
- The (beep)?
(Jaki chuckling)
- Yeah, It's definitely...
I think it's Ricky, for sure.
(timer rings)
- I think I'm pretty safe.
Nobody has like directly
said anything about me.
I think I might vote for Ricky this round,
'cause people are already sus of him.
- I'm gonna vote for Ricky.
I wanna get him outta here
'cause he's sussing me.
- I think I'm gonna vote for Ricky.
- I'm probably going to vote Ricky.
- I'm gonna be voting for Ricky.
- I guess I have to vote Ricky.
- I'm gonna vote for Jaki
because my gut is telling me
it's just like her, maybe.
- The votes are in for round one,
and the person eliminated
in this round is--
- Oh God.
- Ricky.
(all cackling)
- What the hell?
I definitely thought I
was gonna last longer
than just one round.
I really needed that shmoney, you know?
Like who doesn't need money?
- Hoo!
(screen beeping)
- What's everyone's
favorite SSSniperWolf video?
I like the one where
she builds the doghouse.
- [SSSniperWolf] This
is your new puppy house.
It's your new puppy house.
- SSSniperWolf was hysterical.
Aah! (chuckles)
- I love her Fortnite video.
She's such a savage.
- I like her streams.
When she used to, when she
used to stream. (chuckles)
(somber music)
- Oh, her Fortnite videos.
Ooh, I don't know.
I'm still sussing Liz.
(screen beeps)
- "The 24 Hour In Walmart"
video is really good.
(screen beeps)
- They're all (beep) closed.
- Oh they're closed, what the (beep)?
- Home Depo was good too.
Notice how nobody's said,
reacting. (chuckling)
(screen beeps)
"What was the most kills
that she got at Fortnite?"
Bro, even I don't know that.
- I don't know, 100?
- 19 kills mother (beep).
Nobody seems too suspicious,
and nobody seems suspicious of others.
- No one's like answering
questions that much.
- Oh, somebody's sus is--
- Oh we're sussing people.
- Is of Liz.
Because I was gonna say that.
Why is Liz' name orange?
(screen beeps)
(Miley chuckling)
- Why are you sus of Liz?
- I'm a cool mate.
I promise, I'm innocent. (chuckling)
- I thought it was Liz
from her personality.
(screen beeps)
- Has a cute beanie like SSSniperWolf.
- Ask more questions.
- How does she influence--
- They're sus of each other.
- Your lives?
- How does she influence your lives?
Entertainment when I'm bored. (chuckling)
- For me, she taught me to
embrace my true personality,
come out of my shell,
and was a good role model for girl gamers.
- Aw, thanks Emily.
You guys are so sweet, oh.
- I love Emily's response.
Either you're a true gamer or you are Lia.
- She's like, "I love
that response Emily."
I don't know if that's like
genuinely her being nice,
or if that's like SSSniperWolf
being like, "Yep."
- I just said, "Hey," that's not nice.
- People are sussing now also Erika.
(screen beeps)
- She sussed my beanie.
- [Erika] She sussed my beanie.
- Your orange name's sus.
I don't know what it is,
how come all of our names
are in green and blue?
- I feel like Erika's
not texting that much.
- You vote me out, you lose.
That's something SSSniperWolf
would say. (chuckles)
(alarm rings)
- People are sussing Jackie and Liz
for their bitmojis.
- I'm sus of Liz, so
I'm gonna vote for her.
- I'm gonna have to vote for Liz.
- I know people said about her beanie,
but I really think her personality
kind of resembles SSSniperWolf's in a way.
- Probably Jaki.
I'll give Liz the benefit of the doubt.
- Feel dirty voting for Liz,
scumbag even.
- Why is everyone sus of me?
I think I might vote for Emily.
- The person eliminated
in round two is Liz.
(buzzer buzzing)
- Oh.
- Why?
I guess I'm flattered,
but no, I'm not her.
- (laughing maniacally)
Excellent, excellent,
everything's going according to plan.
My strategy for the next
round is to make a friend.
I'm gonna be like, I think
Emily is the real deal
and maybe she'll like, side with me.
(upbeat hiphop music)
So we had to get a TikTok
ready that I would react to.
Who better to ask than me?
- [Machine VO] Poop.
- [Dog Owner] You went poop?
- Oh, it's a smart dog.
Okay, I thought this was funny.
- Why does she keep doing that?
- Oh, yo, Miley is so right.
Miley is so right, she
would totally react to that.
Maybe Miley's SSSniperWolf
'cause that's totally some stuff,
she would love that.
- Okay.
- Jaki, that is a YouTube video, girl.
- One of these videos.
That was the lazy response.
- I'm gonna fail this round.
I'm so bad with the TikToks,
I don't actually know.
- What did Erika send?
- A water pie from the Great Depression.
Blind bake the pastry.
(pot clanking)
That's rude.
All right, finished a
bit early, like my ex.
- I don't think it's SSSiperWolf.
I don't know if she finds this funny,
no offense.
- (chuckling) Oh, somebody linked--
♪ Why the (beep) aren't you vegan yet ♪♪
- Vegan Teacher.
- Huh, the Vegan Teacher.
♪ Why the (beep) ♪
♪ haven't you ate a cheeseburger yet ♪♪
- Okay, whoever posted
that, I'm gonna sus them.
Okay, I'm gonna try blaming people now.
I'm gonna say,
"I'm pretty sure she
reacted to that Brandon."
- (chuckling) Okay Emily.
- Everyone said, "Links except Miley?"
No, don't do this to me.
Don't do this to me, Emily.
I trusted you.
I have them saved.
- She has them saved.
Okay that tracks, that
tracks, that tracks.
- At least Emily and Brandon.
- Everyone's so quiet.
- Anyone sus of anyone?
- Anyone sus of anybody?
Ugh!
- I'm gonna see who they think is sus.
- They're gonna say me, just
'cause I asked that question.
- Everyone seems so nice,
it could be anybody...
Brandon.
- Why me?
'Cause I--
- Brandon.
I'll vote him out just to
vote him out. (giggling)
- I really think we voted her out.
Like, she could be gone.
We could have already
voted SSSniperWolf out.
(timer rings)
- I'm gonna say Brandon,
because I feel like people
are either gonna vote for me
without even saying anything
or vote for Brandon.
- No, I feel bad voting him.
- I think I'm gonna vote
out Jaki this round.
- I think it's Brandon.
- The votes are in for round three,
and the person eliminated
in this round is Brandon.
- (gasping) Woo, hoo-hoo!
Safe another round.
- [Brandon] I knew I
was gonna get voted out.
- Goodbye Brandon.
Good knowing you.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- If everyone feels confident
that you already voted out the mole,
then you can end the game now.
If the majority has doubt,
the game will continue.
- Okay, I'll give a thumbs up.
I think we got her.
- Okay, I'm gonna give
a thumbs up right now.
- I wanna keep going.
- If the colors behind me show green,
that means you all win
and SSSniperWolf has been eliminated.
If the colors behind me turn red,
that means that SSSniperWolf
is still in the game
and you all lost.
- It's gonna be red.
It's gonna be red, it's gonna be red.
All right, let's see it.
Let's go.
Let me see that screen bleed.
(all yelling)
(upbeat instrumental music)
- [Ragini] Turn on your
camera in three, two, one.
(screen chiming)
- Oh.
- Hey.
- Hi, y'all.
(all giggling)
- You sussed me so quick.
- I'm so sorry.
I had to do it to you guys.
- I thought it was you at the end
when you sussed me for guessing the video
that you already reacted to.
- I had to, I had to.
- Thank you so much for making a platform
where girl gaming is a thing.
Thank you so much for like
paving the path for us.
- Aw, of course.
Thanks. (chuckling)
It just, it really means a lot to me,
especially when you guys
were like talking about that in the chat,
and I was like getting emotional.
I was like, "You guys are so (beep) nice."
- I would watch you
before I was a creator,
and now I'm a creator and you
reacted to me on your YouTube.
And now I'm talking to
you in this game show,
so this is pretty cool.
I just love you.
I hope you know that.
- You guys are awesome.
You guys are gonna make me tear up.
This is like so sweet.
- Literally, Miley was the last person
I was going to vote out.
Like, seriously.
- I definitely thought Lia
was a good liar. (chuckling)
- Being a fan of SSSniperWolf
means engaging and being
part of this community
that uplifts girl gamer voices,
and uplifts each other, and supporting,
and getting through all these
hard times that we're having
while still being fun and personable.
And letting yourself be free.
- I'm so glad that I got to experience it.
It was so fun.
- You know, if I wanted to put
somebody on blast right now
I think it should be Dhar Mann.
Dhar Mann should be doing this next.
It's so nice meeting you guys
like this is so sweet,
and it's awesome that I
could like, inspire you.
Sorry, I was just like
awkward. (chuckling)
Like, I really appreciate you guys
like playing this game with me.
And it was super fun.
And it was so nice to meet all of you.
Mhm, I can't wait to
react to this. (chuckles)